[Music]
some people have been complaining about
true news the CEO that news from was
last week's it's not current enough I
know you want current news got a fox
go ask I got a CNN don't go to Fox got
one of them lock Jerry this is the real
[__] like where we cut through it we
tell you what you really need to know
about the news it's the true news
[Music]
what's the headline this week bring up
YouTube
yep hey Lawrence bring up YouTube I was
in the barbers the other doing people
just kept shouting at Alexa every five
seconds I was like this is doing I'm
getting [__] heavy what were they
saying what sort of stuff they say Alexa
shut up my barbershop I love them but
like they were trying to like annoy each
other by skipping the trucks of the
world
Alexa yeah yeah yeah I love you guys but
that was a hard day
Brooklyn rapper Takashi 69 pleaded
guilty to federal charges admitting he
participated in a violent game which
could include murder robbery extortion
or drug distribution he was facing a
mandatory 47 year prison sentence
that'll make you a cop do it 47 years
yeah that will make more cement be like
I probably don't want to do that
big joke yesterday everyone's going do
you know how old he is he's 22 47 years
six thing he's [__] it basically it is
short he's he's [__] it all because he
wanted a bit of clout it's not enough
that he's getting money he wants to be
feared the first Breakfast Club
interview he was like test my gangsta
I taught everybody all the time test my
gangsta you're about 5 foot you're not a
hard case so in order to prove himself
he's obviously being shocked no tre away
and all that this garden that he
represented he was basically just a
front man for them no he wasn't
he's hardly the [__] shooter he's a
shoot shoot out as a shooter so he's
caught the way he's pled guilty which
means they must have great evidence on
him otherwise he would have because he's
got money to fight this for someone else
broke and then he was like [__] it I've
got a break as well also agree to
cooperate which means he's probably
gonna double his mates in as well which
really none of them are exactly looking
after him so I can understand why he
would do that at this point we spoke
into Sean Atwood who was in the same
jail same situation Rocketeer and all of
that instead of the 47 years that's
being bandied about willy-nilly yeah
which is basically for headlines and
cliques it's more likely that you'll do
under 10 years 47 names they'll probably
give them something under turn you'll do
half of that you'll get out on house
arrest a while maybe ableton 5 years so
you can have his career back there he
might not be as good as like to partner
57 he's definitely not let's be honest
or their prime but he has this like
energy about him that might be gone in
five years time well five years time
also a lot changes in music in five
years so he's kind of music
this music isn't it's not artistic it's
not shouting [__] I'm silly which I
mean we know that yeah I wonder if the
judgment yes you are I kind of feel like
rap is so boring without him because he
is such like in a room full of
personalities he just stands out no no
you know you know my father always did
you tell somebody suck man you got to be
ready to either kill or die I die in
prison yes he's ready to cooperate with
the authorities
I'm ready did I kill or cooperate if
someone were for me they would have been
found me give us some time Charlamagne
would in the end in me yeah everyone
said six time abut Charlemagne modern
yeah everything he said is basically
come true yeah and Charlie basically sat
back and won't give it some time you
know they'll come for you and they did
boom-boom so for those who don't know
serial killers normally they don't kill
Frosty's they don't kill rice krispies
these men kill people people serially
serial killers obviously normally or and
I don't want to provoke any yeah
no offense to any of you hope if you're
watching them leave me alone serial
killers don't tend to go you've provoked
me are there many serial killers that's
that's what worries me is they don't
usually need provoking so if I'm picking
on them probably not a good idea
but this sad little weirdos who live in
the mother's basement and right don't
have many friends something's gone wrong
basically along the way do you know what
I mean
yeah yeah the difference is with this
guy Ted Bundy
he was good-looking Charmin popular
charismatic intelligent I'll say this
right I think Ted Bundy was good looking
for a serial killer when you look at him
he doesn't look like he doesn't but
they've definitely made Zac Efron look
more like him and come to a happy medium
where a bit like a lot of films it's
it's glamorized right they've done that
which is what you want to do about
serial killing do you know what I mean
that's the question yeah and I don't
have you seen that there's a lot of
controversy in that the trailer for this
movie isn't really of a tone of a serial
killing story
that guy's been staring at you all night
what do you say we get out
I can't help but think for Zac Efron
when you've been pigeon-holed as a
certain kind of actor to a bit like when
DiCaprio went off and played wolf of
wallstreet and they've definitely taken
a lot of inspiration from that it's
great for him as an actor plays someone
in healer who was dark and horrible and
all the things that he has never been in
his previous character but also still
beautiful I want to see you it was
really really sounds like him as well to
be face done a good job in the corridor
I mean credit ladies and gentlemen I am
you are skating on thin ice this was
what made him different is he defended
himself he was so arrogant well he was
also trained in law wasn't he on some
confident arrogant and he gets up there
he knows the law and he's defending
himself people who would be related to
the victims of him I'm gonna say this
and be like you make and the guy who
killed my grandmother auntie what sister
whatever I would be some sort of hero
yeah I feel like they're telling the
story how Ted Bundy would want it told
marvel at him admire him and you are
going to do that when you watch a movie
like this you do these things
the trailer will often be salacious the
trailer will often be sort of you know
it makes me want to watch it hummus
which it's worked but the other side of
it is if you then get there and there is
a tragic side to it there's a side where
you know he's heartbroken all these
things it shows the other side but
you've been already yeah I just hope
when the movie players and he's drugging
that woman's dead body into the forest
and yeah I hope there's like music that
matches the mood yes killing an innocent
woman yeah yeah read what the [__]
judge says as he says some wage isn't it
he admired him didn't he he admired him
a lot you're a total waste of all
humanity I've seen on this courtroom I
don't know to have you practice in front
of me what would you love to watch him
do judge suck on these big ol balls I
don't know if that balls
it is that holy Eddie oh my god teddy
I'll bet I bet you were to go home that
I wanted to free you teddy I wanted to
put you not guilty you see there were
too much evidence I would have let you
go boy you handsome young man Wow 50
cent soup I sang a tiara Murray for
alleged revenge porn Instagram post
there wasn't fifty with her though was
it not was a boyfriend
who's called akbar abdul ahad he's
basically busted not all over her face
after she sucked this child his good
friend fifty said has posted the photo
of me to his Instagram and Rob said get
the strap so fifty Cent said da baby
this reality TV [__] gone too far what
you doing this for 50 cent has 18
million followers so I was devastated
and to make it even worse
even after Instagram took the pitch down
he had no remorse no regard and he
posted another photo and complained that
IG was censoring him
just be careful when you're dealing with
a man with a lot of followers because
men can
wild like this germ says right but do
you not think that's a bit of a [__] no
it's not exactly home from 50 but she
sued him she's trying to get money out
of 50 and now she's 30 grand
he keeps posting on Instagram with a
picture of her every week on where's my
money [__]
you owe me 30 grand I need that money
now when it comes to a bottle of I who
gives less of a [__] you don't want to
be in that bottle with 50 cent not
really just doesn't really we'll take it
as far as the hostage this isn't the
first time he's posted [__] like this
and women have tried to sue and baby
mamas whatever he went back up just to
be like you can't touch me you can't get
any of my money you cannot endorse
revenge point it's a horrible thing no I
would never you don't post anything the
girls sent you ever yes just for the
worse the most humiliating thing you
only do to a young woman you're so
wonderful for this but he is quite a
funny guy but this isn't right and it's
all of evil especially see her face
covered in [__] it's not fair right
apparently there was a zoella bro moment
right zoella David Brent
I don't think of myself as famous I just
have a lot of people who know who I am
one thing this just sounds really weird
to me because I'm just me not also see
I'm not really interesting but obviously
well six million people or I think I am
sorry Alfie but you have to know that
it's funny do you think there is an
element of it is hard for most people to
understand their own fame like they a
lot of people don't know what Fame is I
mean I don't know the girl but I don't
think she's as like she comes across
there that is not yet that's not good
look as it is that was so prevalent old
Alfie to get better content from years
ago he's got a couple of new things were
so the one way answers problems from his
audience on a podcast any interviewed a
London gangster as well so you know me
so get get better content we didn't mean
get my content do you remember when
there Paul McCartney told Michael
Jackson you need to buy the rights to
songs that's where the real money is in
the Michael Jackson bought all the
rights to Paul McCartney songs your Paul
McCartney um he's Michael Jackson I'm
McCartney and yeah I'm more than happy
to have it that way around yeah
absolutely I don't want to be Michael
trucks especially with the documentary
looming and the whole head of mills
thing and I've shagged a one-legged
Geordie killed before no I haven't um we
actually made every front page and news
every good you know when cutting a
preview try and get to the key part not
the bit where the guy goes okay Ken do
you know me Oh Alfie Kim dressed as
Eminem and eight-mile for this just
because he was interviewing a black guy
he's also looking at him going oh my god
what disappointed this I've seen one
clip way he's going on about getting it
good and all feels I wouldn't have an
idea we know the Alfie
we hardly think the York scarrans did
anyone know get a piece yes but let you
say the next landmark was noise is this
man is a beat
that I know that I know is a fact I feel
like we need to go and see the road
let's do it
I just really hope that we're going into
some sauce sex room you know like with
is like stirrups and all about that okay
hoist the men under we need to get
people like this on the vodka crazy love
to chat I think I understand the roadies
going down I think
Alfie's strength isn't in this book good
good luck that when he's trying
something different I respect God a load
of [__] science stuff that he's laid out
all of a sudden I really love this yeah
Alfie smiling because he hasn't he's
terrified inside and no idea what to do
paper mache basically more than Steve
all proved but it is very cool I don't
know if you of all the people I could
have courted a member of Jackass I
didn't think would be the one but coming
up evils and this is me filming myself
like look at that oh my god it's like
it's [__] night up there Wow that's
for anybody wants to say that the
[__] world is flat that's what I
could prove [__] I wasn't
nothing at it for me though you don't
think I've seen about that red bull jump
we're trying to prove the world is
spherical here
that's pretty bloody round isn't it you
could say that's also because of the
lens so you don't know if I was a genius
computer guy could I edit that and make
a look more curvy oh you can add
anything I mean he could be jumping out
in a green screen at this point I mean
look real spa flat after all this cell
is confirmed that laws cus confirmed
confirmed the earth is indeed flat what
are we watching here we're watching a
girl who's a gymnast right
she's just unbelievable she's like world
champion level right what she does yeah
watch what I just then she goes a little
moody got a butt look at that I won't
stop the pub I mean that good all of her
girls given her a bit moral support
absolutely yeah but when you look really
close they're loving her but some of
them are pulling some some odd little
face you know they're happy I mean I'd
be happy if I was front row watching
that move around in front of me I
Cornell watch I think she must be
amazing in bed what she does things and
you're just like you just wonder what an
absolute animal like this could do she's
a beast in the best way possible
anything I don't just want to know what
she's like that that I want to see I do
lots of things like what yoga I was
there big finale I think it's common
she gonna wow really boom boom boom
Oh bang nailed it Rai fat booty lovely
why you was looking at her ass another
news story Prince Phillip 97 years old
khakhra driving in the prime of your
life requires a lot of you have to be
switched on I mean we're what around you
what's happening at all time and are
fairly quick reactions at it that is
going to be almost impossible the woman
wants an apology I submit she's arms be
enough Turin apologize we came past the
junction at Sandringham
stationary vehicle to the left of us
made the decision to put into our past
because he's a 97 year old man he
doesn't look at both ways he just
[__] does what he wants he owns the
[__] country law if you think event
what's this the query site the passage I
see I got to impress her it's gonna take
a lot to get our wet at this edge I was
up for you love [__] it was reported
that the Juke said that it was a son
that dazzled him does
blinds accelerate I don't remember it
being sunny that day I would never want
to put myself in a position where I
would say the Jew is not being honest
she's just insinuating that the Dukes
are [__] liar I'm not saying he's a
liar but that's not what I remember
yeah I'm not saying he's a liar but
that's not true so what is it that are
you looking for an apology direct from
the palace I'd love sure what mud the
funny thing would be now if they went
well we've got him here now live and he
just pops up from behind with a giant
novelty check I'm gonna give you 30,000
know 40 50 50 grams yet 50 grands we're
at the castle today innit we're either
side of the movie the side of the dock
we've got my big you know the big cool
things that they have on their head
protect the royal family yeah as always
so still the same task so if thou hast
50 [__] is we're looking we're looking
in the distance they just you know I
thought it'd be perfect you're sold
you're hopping the phone yes don't know
what he's got he's got a 97 year old man
hopping a fence there he's hopped the
fence right on he's up he's in the car
oh he's gone is that Prince Phillip yeah
you do know you're gonna be a world star
if I was the security guy and principal
shouted in my face got that broad bond I
have my hand on the gun he looks evil
principal can we get a picture of Prince
Phillip evil Prince in it click on that
one tell me doesn't look evil there
that's an evil man I'd say this person
looks evil that's an evil eye shut the
next one would have faced like that kill
Lady Diana
lived your life like a candle reading
that was a song about Marilyn Monroe was
another person murdered I think that was
the chord from Elton that was Elton
scored to us the Queen must be angry
without John cuz he's a bit of a queen
whose name no wonder I'm still stand in
the air than
if that's what the Queen got as a
private performance after she went a
shows like this one I'm still standing
kill Diana in a tunnel like Philip goes
world star to the Queen without the use
of drugs yeah the budget is high yeah
we're gonna have to go look and you're
gonna have to imagine as high because
we've never done the reefer how the
Queen uses her handbag to send secret
signals to her staff and what it means
if you see her twist her wedding ring
you know how when Rafa Benitez wins a
game of football buses are off in the
pot man that's him certainly be like we
fought you so so maybe if you put
something in her bag it means she needs
a [__] and then if it's a really big
item
it's a massive [__] a third secret
signal is a discreet twist of her
wedding ring which the Queen uses to
emphasize that she'd like to be moved on
from the conversation quickly so all
these signals the worry for me would be
now people know this the Queen must have
to have come up with new signals because
if you see the Queen hmm
and you're going [__] stop and in the
chat you [__] like you're angry with
her yeah she's there going I mean yeah
there's but Britain was not Britain news
was true news I think I know where
you're going with this this girl
Lawrence yeah I was gonna go
instagram.com /what is it so using this
graph or one with high s KRA you just
say it I prefer the other picture of
them I think she's got a type I mean
yeah yeah not me basically as a I love
lady fair as much as it broke my little
hot it is a nice picture every time you
saw the tag did your little heart break
a bit why did you have to keep letting
me know about this I'm getting on with
my life now I've accepted just found
someone who's they get better stronger
and looking probably I was gonna say
probably better than me in many ways yes
I'm just moving aside now Annie she's
made a choice so long he's being stalked
tugging me in her pictures hot be hot to
recover a million Iskra it's not gonna
happen
I've accepted it you know my favorite
cake that you bought me I'm not even
[__] you like I couldn't believe
this right after this came out
she baked him from scratch a red velvet
kick I literally thought he's living my
dream and in icing on the top it
probably said [__] Trudeau and gay now
gain I'll get right okay look you know
probably the only way you're gonna get a
part in her life you could be the gay
best friends oh we can brush up any
scratch that one never mind I'll find
someone like you wish for you Charles
a man who paints his face for a living
[__] me now
did a youtuber cause gridlock in
Birmingham city centre over the weekend
well Birmingham certainly felt the full
impact of the popularity of James
Charles on Saturday someone's now
skeptical of who James Charles is James
Shaw James Charles city centre was
jammed with some wrote at a standstill
for hours
some people even ditched their car I
love the sound of this guys I'd love to
hear his sex talk with his wife if you
could lick on my own balls of me
fantastic
get the ballot in your mouth orgy
darling Isis been a while hasn't it we
brought in a young woman who seems to
know about who these characters are
fantastic Sarah
lots of talk allegedly you have a
Twitter account yes I've been checking
things on a hashtag that's almost
irrelevant now and I'm going to tell you
some information that most people
already know first for those of us who
don't know at the risk of showing my
face showing my age as if no-one already
knew I was a geriatric [__] that yes
that is amazing we both acted like as a
fellow youtuber you look like you fits a
[__] I'll Fairplay make people give a
[__] about you I'll be honest I also
don't want Matt not me neither well the
boring has said it was a great thing
that he came to Birmingham his first UK
appearance and that the city centre
congestion was most likely caused
because of ongoing road work that would
do really and not to do with an extra
10,000 people yeah it's the roadworks
because I take advice of a woman not a
man she wasn't too impressed with that
was she if a man had a comment about
what a woman should I shouldn't do oh I
think the only reason she's being taken
to task a little bit is because you'd
call that a gamer girls have got his
back in that respect so therefore the
Tom's like he's one of them sort of
thing whereas if it was just a woman
having to go any old man they wouldn't
have even been any backlash all right
understood I mean I don't know of people
probably argue with me in the comments
but deep down you know I'm [__] what
if James came to UK and went there's
only one huge youtuber that I want to
collaborate with this man but he has to
put makeup on would I let you in Charles
makeup me would you let James Charles
makeup you yeah yeah yeah well I'll be
[__] stupid not do I've got really
long eyelashes or be a nice chance from
Missha off that the pretty side of news
you know and I'm saying the eyes the
cheekbones you could show it all off so
you're saying that you would let James
Charles decorate your face in makeup
right got sponsor yep you did so when
they called me and say hey yeah that is
actually a lovely jacket not yeah nice
calm calm and calm who sponsored us yeah
calm were and indeed are the app of the
year on calm calm forward slash Geordi
guess you 25% off their premium
subscription which I personally can
recommend as I have signed up to them
for a little while I was thinking you
know I've got a lot we do a lot together
we need to be able to stay on top of it
and I need to have a calm mind so it's
basically a meditation app move no no no
no guided meditations which help with
things like anxiety stress and focus so
I did it for focus and of course there's
soothing music breathing exercises and
gentle stretches to relax your body I'm
gonna start the gentle stretches this
week have another time yet and there's
there's a love a little thing when you
open up the app let me just sort show
you
it's got relaxing noises I have rain I
also have other ones you can have the it
just the movement of the earth about my
trick I use a really good point but that
don't have the spherical earth of your
aflutter over it one calmly does it'll
just annoy you
that's lovely isn't it the point is that
normally you know sometimes a brand
comes to you and they go oh can you say
that you use this well yeah I only turn
them down I do one swing
yeah and you when you said this is good
enough yeah okay I trust you'll know it
is it is good and so it's calm calm at
sea ALM calm forward-slash Jordi you can
get 25% off calm premium physically
support of the podcast and helps prepare
us and Condon who overall Jill at
brilliant yeah it is well worth it I can
personally recommend it of the soil well
done guys you managed to finally
elevators to a point where we get
responses we respect alive much true
news each day watching call my rapist is
being revealed but yeah apart he's a
rapper in a Christian rap group enduring
she was in a vegetative state from an
accident that happened when she was
younger I think she nearly drowned or
something like that
I'm not be [__] perfect but I'm hoping
that that's all correct so she wasn't in
a coma that cousin she was able to make
noise she was able to kind of
communicate in somewhere with the family
thought she wasn't in a coma almost
makes it even worse because she would
have been awake for all that yeah
ultimately this guy is a piece of [__]
good morning look I came into this
thinking who does this kind of thing
right well stephen pruitt does the
virginia native has made nearly 3
million edits on wikipedia 3 million
this guy's made three million edits they
say he's written a ridiculous amount of
wikipedia The Wizard of Wikipedia yeah
he sings like that
yeah you have my attention I want to get
your take on the fact that this man has
done such a service to the community and
yet a lot of people replied of course
he's written a lot of Wikipedia look at
him they fat shamed him essentially boil
and as a man who's been fat shamed a lot
you can relate should we be fat shaming
this man she reminds me of penguin in
the country great friend of the
Fairfax's some have rumored that for a
time he helped carried a torch for the
Lord's wife carried a torch nice way of
saying had a crush yes scandal I just
can't help but think you could he's a
very intelligent guy who could be
getting paid to do something very
intelligent got paid
instead of just filling up Wikipedia
yeah but he's helping other people gain
knowledge do you know what I mean so
he's trying to keep Wikipedia accurate
he's trying to give it something a level
of accuracy that means we can go in
trust it I agree because
you know how like we used to find books
written you know in the 1800s or
whatever and you'd find a good right and
he'd be like oh this guy this was the
one people like him will be like those
guys will I do one when you look at the
Wikipedia names were like oh this this
was a trustworthy yes I can't really say
why I've got interested women I just
guess it's just always been there yeah I
mean they've got big fat tits and a nice
sauce never oh now come on we don't know
that that's the case
he's like one of those guys who if he
did get with a woman he would touch them
in a certain spot on their body that
they had no idea and all of a sudden
he's finding like unreal pleasure they'd
be like unknown I mean yeah I'm into the
obscure but while they're finding that
I'm real pleasure he's listing every
reason why they're finding that I'm real
this is a nerve which most people don't
know in like sort of under the armpit so
yeah any pill something like really
weird and he's like I can't I really
thought you like something which looks
really weird so most people but when you
let him do it
see I told you and that's the weird and
then all of a sudden he's got a woman
who like will love him forever forever I
guess it's because I've always been
interested in things that are that are
less well known I just say I love
earnest people like this people who just
want to be honest they just want to be
nice they want to be a respected figure
and so he's he's never took this man has
never taken the piss out of anything
I mean there is not a bone in his body
which goes loser it because he just goes
absolutely I will catalog this away as a
thing and then we'll just move on with
our lives the food reviewer but of
information is the information reviewer
he's the wiki reviewer he does reviews
of the wiki
you've never knew such a wiki guy he
keeps it so fly and do you know why
because he knows whether to review that
information someone else found the food
reviewer before you and I did but after
I'd originally found him someone else
has been a little mean about our friends
or [__] hell Tyler you guys know that
I have a special place in my fat greasy
heart somewhere for food
mostly because they are the most cringy
obnoxious thing ever
usually conducted by a ball of fat
grease that just wants an excuse to
stuff their face and get the deck
YouTube revenue you think miss Tyler is
in this for the danke YouTube revenue
you are sorely mistaken
it's an awful Beastie Boys yo on the
youtubes I love this you never knew such
a cool dude
I keep it so flat do you know what it's
because I know whether to buy that food
he's not a great actor this guy's you
that's not my first comment about him
but your video literally starts like
this he's singing review our intro just
guns down that [__] let the terminate
every time yeah reviewer I'm not joking
I need to see that one more time that
was possibly one of the worst intros to
a video I've ever seen in my life can we
show this show the thing again grown
again
[Music]
seriously scrap your channel because of
that intro I'm not even joking the
Dominos like a swollen ankle the only
person I've ever seen that isn't a
swollen ankle is Stu and that's because
he's a food review god thanks to his
[__] dick out your mouth for a second
please
yeah but every food review channel out
there there's stuffy at fat and
overweight you know why cuz they're
probably not reviewing food they're
eating it you literally have to do one
in order to do the other how many food
reviews have you seen where they sit
there and go looks good
well join us next week like that's not
only food reviewing word this is the
most angry I've seen you pisses me off
when people bully people for the way
they look and people have a go at you
it's not fair the way they take the piss
at you gold chain you funny little
shirts I want to see what this guy's
comparing into I'm just saying let's say
the god one either you two Stu here back
again with another video that's a really
strange voice for a kid like that he's
also skins came at the Frog and then
stretch avarice bad Ella for new PC kid
sounds like Kermit as well could be a
voice you put on even I can see that
focus none of you guys can see that you
know the food
without focus focus focus your focus
she's fought this foolish lovely fellows
oh it took two you always gotta take two
oh that that's food reviewer stunned
yeah in the industry three bites oh is
this gonna go five bites good okay he's
not as good as Tyler no no way no no way
what it's broken but when I went down I
thought of Tyson Fury probably know for
the first time a bit of a difference
fury is it in a title fight for the
World Heavyweight Championship
Timothy embossing takes a punch from
probably the hardest puncher in decades
she just fell over she lost her balance
but it's a big moment for her in her
life and relatively big mom this is her
this is her never have thought be more
more this is her here she comes
he she's gonna do the fall thing boom
I'm happy that she's falling over I am
just calling her on shutting [__] about
comparing herself to Tyson [__] fury
she I think she is the equivalent of
Tyson Fury on the ice
she's ice and fury in the respect that
she shouldn't be able to move but she
does move yes
[Music]
by July Allah those sheep songs Banyon
oh haha
how hum how singing that's what you just
said I'm already sure then this is what
happens when you try and grow a brand
out and do like the Far Eastern that
isn't it yeah oh gee how ma this is mod
[Music]
if need castle we're doing stuff like
this and we went buying players and
strengthening the squad it would really
piss me off further it would really
annoy me I agree yeah it's like what the
[__] are we doing it means how are you
me how ma Brian me how ma how can and be
lucky their words
yeah Messer awesome 350 grand do we
contract then hit B lucky you are
[__] lucky what house bought a car a
promotion I pay rise to perceived a red
envelope married yet this is mental I
can only assume in in Chinese culture
that this sounds normal because to us it
sounds absolutely mint I mean of course
it does a saying in Chinese oh my god oh
well that was just a lovely touching and
perfectly naturally executed
shut up perfectly naturally executed
piece of content that's enough for one
day lawrence we've we've covered a lot I
feel sick today is true news if there's
anything you wanted to cover in future
we do let us know and you can be
expecting a podcast coming soon Tresor
you ricky gervais remember and keep this
in your hearts niihama
glioma